okay can you just say and spell your
first and last name and then your super
job title yes my first name is joe j-o-e
my last name is yalda y-a-l-d-a
uh my title is vice president of guest
experience for red rock casino
awesome let's get started joe first of
all i just have to ask for station
casinos as kind of a collective feeling
what does it feel like
to see someone who's filing faces back
on your many properties
after really an unprecedented year and a
half you know the best way to describe
it it feels like home again
we have all our guests here our team
members are here and the resilience of
the city really shone and we are back to
normal now
you guys are going to go back to normal
where the bank has some fireworks in a
couple of weeks
celebrating the 45th anniversary of
stations talk about
that plan to really make it a party yeah
so we opened our doors in 1976 uh
frankfurt
jr did and changed the industry forever
we're celebrating our 45 years july 1st
we're going to celebrate with some
fireworks so at palace station on july
1st you'll be able to catch some
fireworks and then fourth of july here
in green valley ranch we're going to
have a big firework show for the
community and that is
what stations did for their employees
talk about
the effort on behalf of station casinos
and its leaders to make sure
employees were taken care of during such
a trying time
you know it was such a time of
uncertainty for all of us but one thing
that was never foreshadowed was our team
members are our family and they were
always priority for frank lorenzo
fertitta and for the company itself
so we paid our team members all the way
through the closure and then we even
doubled down to increase their
uh at a company paid retirement fund and
then to top it all off anybody making
less than a hundred thousand dollars a
year gets free
uh health benefits and free insurance
for them and their family
[Music]
because of what members going on in the
world and so many people being laid off
and so many people not being paid
we heard from everybody i mean to
provide that kind of comfort in a time
where
everybody doesn't know what's going on i
mean that speaks volumes for just the
company itself and how it works
as people are starting to return you
mentioned it feels like
what are they gravitating towards i'm
curious is it
everything is it more hey i really want
to go out to a restaurant or bar
is it a lot of the gaming anything
specific people really seem to have
missed the most
you know it is a little bit of
everything and the one main thing is the
relationships that we have with all our
guests and we continue to build as we
move forward
a lot of people return for one reason
only and it's our team members
goal for both themselves who like
station properties but also locals who
consider it
their casino we make it a very fun safe
and clean environment
everybody comes here with the priority
knowing that they are number one to us
and we'll always build that relationship
and continue on as great as the strip is
when you come here
again you really do feel like you're at
home how challenging was it
what was the biggest challenge last
summer with reopening in a very
different way than now
how did you transcend that challenge in
all your properties it must have been
quite a mountain
um it definitely was but the one thing
about our properties here at station
casinos is we're always known to be the
cleanest and the safest our priority are
always our team members and our guests
so to take that and enhance it just a
little farther to ensure that sense of
comfort with all our guests as
challenging as it was was easy to a
company like ours and we were able to do
it with
immense success now looking at the now
in the future with business booming and
returning
what does the company foresee with so
many people clearly ready
to see live music again gamble go to
restaurants and bars and just be out
what does it mean what is the foresight
you know we're looking to expand more we
have more properties coming in the
future we're going to add more shows
that come down the safety standards are
still in place nothing has changed there
and more importantly we just want
everybody to come and have a great time
at stations
is there a most exciting part for the
station casinos
the aspect of when leaders look at this
is there a most exciting part of
finally we're turning the corner i think
the most exciting part was getting all
our team members back to work
and then providing and opening our doors
for all the guests that not only come
from california but our most important
guests are local guests
well we appreciate you being a part of
our community prize special
we're glad to have you at station
casinos as a part of the community thank
you very much john
thank you sir thank you everybody
thank you